free palese free free pales live
Palestine live palese got to
go OCC
has parents and kids are taking note and
they're watching and also the kids who
are um in 11th grade in applying or
watching so it'll be very interesting to
see what happens and and how they kind
of rectify the situation because the
things that we are seeing and I know
sometimes it can feel
sensationalized but they're happening
and they have to they have to stop you
can't be locking kids in a you know in a
in a library or like writing saskas all
over her school like that's those are
actual crimes hi my name is Jennifer
broos I run a company called peas
private education advisory Service uh we
have been um working with families for
about 16 years and my business partner
and I started this to really help
families find the best fit schools this
problem stems from the the top of a
university that's where that's where we
start because this kind these kind of
protests and hateful actions and
violence would not be happening on uh
college campuses if they were not
allowed to be I've spoken to a multitude
of families and I deal with this every
day uh it's being dealt with in many
different ways one of the ways that it's
dealt with is um kids are just taking
schools off of their list they're no
longer applying another way that they're
dealing with it you know this um uh
October 7th happened while kids were
really gearing up to early decision a
college which is really first choicing a
college and sometimes those colleges are
a little bit of a reach for a student um
but they really want to go there uh so
there's still some kids going to Ed
those schools that they might not feel
the safest in but now their list has
grown and they're applying to a whole
bunch of other schools and they're going
to wait and see they are going to wait
can see what is what happens and the
first time ever that I've heard this
this year they might not honor their Ed
which is a contract by the way and they
really might not because if they want a
school but they that the administration
at these schools need to step up and
these kids need to feel safe third thing
that is happening a lot of kids are
taking Gap years they're saying no I'm
not just waiting and seeing a couple of
months I want to see real change and
until that time happens I'm not you know
going to a certain School parents don't
want to pay it's very expensive to go to
college so they're going to do something
very
meaningful uh for for the next year and
that I think is is um good idea for many
they're also not looking at Elite
schools in the same way it's not always
about the name at this point it's
changing because of this they're looking
at Elite as a place that they feel
valued
respected they can have a voice that
they feel that they're going to be
protected and safe as a parent of four
um my husband and I have four kids we
have two who are grown they're in their
20s and two um school age kids a
freshman in high school and a sixth
grader um my kid our families uh were
were black and were Jewish and the idea
that I would send my my 14-year-old to
any University where he I he's going to
knowingly encounter uh anti-Semitism or
be targeted or be forced to be stay you
know behind locked doors in a cafeteria
because there's a mob outside a Lynch
Mob outside targeting him is abhorent
and ridiculous it's completely
re-evaluated what we discuss as far as
as um where he will be going to
University and obviously the same for my
daughter but she she's only in sixth
grade so hopefully things will improve
before then if they don't there's I'm I
mean I'm not sending my child to to
college to be to be lynched and it's the
disheartening part is this isn't just
students what we're seeing is professors
leading the calls um the discriminatory
calls for more of the same and I think
that is I mean that's that's not
scholarship that's not that's not um a
learning environment that that any
parent expects their kids to go to and
it's not that I expect it to be perfect
you know we live in a world where there
are racist people and there are bigots
and you know people will encounter them
but to see it institutionalized in
systems of education is more than um any
parent or any student should should put
up with I don't think it's going to blow
over quickly no I think there's there's
just too much happening right now and
it's too many people are just up in arms
one way or another of course it'll fade
over time but I think these
conversations have been started and I
think they need to continue I think
they're really important conversations
and about anti fitis but also about
everyone about feeling safed and valued
and and really what education is
supposed to be giving our our kids and
what they have to do is really I change
change the way that their bias really is
right now and they have to take a strong
stand where whatever the head person
believes whatever teachers believe they
have to take a stand that every student
is valued everyone and I I I'm yes we're
talking about anti-Semitism right now
but I mean every student there's no room
in these institutions for hate speech
hate crimes in any way and for every
student not to feel
[Music]
safe